let's talk about what it takes to do a
first draft on a hundred thousand word
novel have you ever heard of Brendan
Sanderson and his crazy writing
productivity if you don't know what I'm
talking about just look at this graph so
in this graph we see multiple authors
and how fast they wrote and Brandon CERN
is slowly catching up to the fastest
writing authors amongst the world so
something that I wanted to do is look
into his writing routine his habits and
his tricks and try them for 24 hours to
see if I can learn something from them
and hopefully by implementing some of
his tips his habits and techniques I can
improve my writing skill success in all
aspects of Life can often be traced to
learning how to make yourself do the
things you want to have done so hello
I'm Charlotte rasa a third year PhD
student in conversational neuroscience
and this week I have to finish a paper
so I have been working on this project
for some time now and I have to write
everything up and if you have ever had
to written a paper yourself or if you
have ever written a part of a book you
know how hard it is to get started and
how hard it is to stay in the flow of
writing so something that I've been
doing is looking at different authors
and their routines to see if I can gain
some tips and someone that really stood
out to me is Brandon Sanderson so
Brandon Sanderson is one of my favorite
authors he wrote The Way of Kings which
is his latest series which I highly
recommend if you're into fantasy but
something that I also notice is the
speed at which he wrote so on this
website for example he shows his
progress in these progress bars and you
can see that he's actually writing
multiple books at the same time and
these are not small books like some of
his books spread over like 500 pages so
I really wanted to know and learn how he
does it so the first thing that I did is
of course look him up and he actually
has a writing course which I highly
recommend to follow it was actually
really interesting so in the first
lesson he gives some tips about his
writing routine and how he stays so fast
in his writing and in the following
lectures he gives a little bit more
advice about how to structure your story
and all of them are pretty good but
especially lecture one so for example
something that he says is that there's
no right way to write a book but there
are some commonalities and what is most
important as a writer is actually making
good habits and writing consistently and
this is something that I as a researcher
also really recognize that when I looked
at different habits from fellow
researchers it's not really that there's
one consistent schedule that works the
best for everyone but it's more that
consistency every day is kind of key so
for example something that Brandon
Sanderson has said is those who
interview me seem to have trouble
understanding this fundamental part of
who I am that writing for me Isn't so
much about performance as it is about
exploration and patient I love Bros both
literary and Commercial and I think I
write great Bros I've slaved over my
style practicing for decades honing it
for crisp and Clarity my process usually
intended to convey ideas theme and
character then get out of the way
because that's how I strive to bring
everyone inside and I think this is such
a beautiful quote and he has many more
in his lecture Series so look it up but
from his lectures and also from his
online websites there were five key
points that he said that really stood
out to me as to his writing routine so
the first one is that he writes about
500 Words an hour and he writes about
eight hours every day the second one is
that he loves bumping multiple ideas the
third one is writing even when you are
not writing the fourth one is when stock
diverse with another project and the
fifth one is having one consistent place
and time for writing so in the next 24
hours I'm gonna try to implement these
ideas and let's see how it goes
maybe so I woke up this morning around
seven and maybe something that you know
about some Brandon Sanderson is that
he's actually a famous Knight Rider so
something that he loves to do is that
after he put his kids to bed right for
another four hours in the middle of the
night so he says I'm a Knight Rider I've
always been a bit of an insomaniac and
I've built my pre-publication career off
the back of working a graveyard shift at
the hotel during which I would write
books at the front desk and this works
very well for me but then actually
something that Brandon Sanderson said in
his lecture is that it doesn't really
matter what time you write so for him
the night shift worked very well because
he was a bit an insomniac but for other
people if you are a morning person and
you can find four hours every morning
every day to write that's also fine so
it's more about the consistency of the
writing than that is about a specific
time so he said also for example try
writing on your lunch hour try getting
up a few hours earlier every day try
turning off the television or World of
Warcraft and spending that time on your
novel experiment the goal is to show
yourself that you can make room for
writing in your life then when the month
is sure try keeping those habits up and
I think this is really good advice so
try not to exactly follow his routine
but try to just find throughout your
life and throughout your day a few hours
that you can can consistently spend for
writing so for me personally this is for
example in the morning or a few hours
after lunch and I do have quite a normal
routine in the sense that I usually go
to UNI and I write there for example but
something that worked really well for me
is that when I had to work on something
that was outside of my main University
life I usually would wake up really
early that's also why I sometimes film
these videos for example really early in
the morning before I go to university
just because for me making some time
extra in the morning is a lot easier
than making some time in evening just
because I'm not an evening person but
try to experiment yourself and see if
you can find some early morning hours
for riding
so our second tip that Sanderson gave
was actually to try bumping multiple
ideas so he has said that now as I've
explained I have a lot of ideas the good
ones are the ones that stick in my head
and keep coming back however one thing I
noticed about newer writers is that they
often latch onto a single idea and try
to make a novel out of it let me enforce
something very strongly here one idea no
matter how brilliant does not make
enough of all one idea probably won't
even make a short story I'd say that a
novel needs at least six and a short
story needs at least two the numbers
will differ but the thing to keep in
mind is that you can't generally carry a
story on just one concept so for me this
idea really resonated also as a PhD
student because something that I noticed
as a PhD student is that you have to
come up with a lot of research ideas
because a lot of them will probably not
work out so if you're doing research or
if you're writing a paper or if you're
thinking about a book it's actually good
to generate multiple ideas and guidance
by bumping them together or bumping them
off of each other and see what comes out
of it instead of just thinking of one
really good idea and hoping that that
one will win the Nobel Prize what I do
in my life is I do two writing sessions
I'm very I you need about a two to four
hour chunk anything less than that and I
generally can't work on new Pros to
attract so I've been writing for a
couple of hours and something that I
always notice when I start writing on my
paper are chapter for a book or even a
tweet it's not the beginning for me is
so hard and actually Brandon Sanderson
has some advice for this as well so
something that he said as well is I was
going to keep going even if I didn't get
published and he also said keep trying
and work for it and that's something
that I think is really good advice
especially in writing because the
beginning is just really really hard
usually when you're working on a new
idea just to get in the flow you just
need to get started so just writing a
few sentences of paper can work or even
writing a little bit on your whiteboard
if you have one or just talking through
some ideas with your friends and that's
mostly to get you started because I
think a lot of us have the tendency to
get to editing our words as we are
writing them and this is actually super
are counterproductive because if you're
editing yourself as you're writing
you're usually left with nothing so I
think especially at the beginning it's
good to just start writing your paper
start writing the introduction or the
results or things you already kind of
have in the back of your mind and then
the rest will flow naturally and also
something else that burnison talked
about which I really really liked is to
the idea of writing when you are not
writing and he says half moments where
you are thinking about writing whilst
doing something else AKA cleaning mowing
the lawn Etc and I think that's almost
the same as what I talked about in the
video of Einstein and that's to think
about ideas whilst you're doing
something else because sometimes you're
just a little bit stumped on a certain
part of your paper or a certain part of
your writing process and as you are
doing something that is a little bit
distracting but not too extract
distracting you can kind of think of the
clue or a little extra part of your
novel that needs to be added and I think
by doing this you can kind of slowly
work through the little knots of your
story without getting too stuck on the
finer details so try for yourself to
find an activity that you can do that
kind of relaxes you whilst you can also
think about certain parts of the story
you are still working on and let me know
how it goes
but writing is one of those that if you
let it it will consume everything and
something else to add reninson also
talks about is that it's actually quite
easy to get burned out as a writer and I
think these kind of professions like
writer and scientists can kind of really
transfers the boundaries of work-life
balance so usually people that are
really motivated in their daily work
that really love their job are actually
the people that also take this work home
a lot and that's something I also
noticed and that kind of brings me to
today's sponsor which I wanted to talk
about and that's Aura so one thing that
I've been focusing on this week a week
of course is writing and how to improve
the writing process and one major part
of that is focus so or as this new
mindfulness and sleep app that won the
best of Apple award and it's used by
over 7 million people it's an all-in-one
app for well-being and sleep and has
thousands of meditation stories and so
much more like like CBT life coaching
and breath work oras content is created
by hundreds of experts coaches and
therapists around the world so I've been
using Aura a little bit to improve my
focus and I've been doing these simple
challenges for improving your focus and
Clarity using Aura for a little bit over
I think two months now and I have to say
I really like their guided meditations
so get started for completely free on
aura's website using my special link in
the description box the first 500 people
get a free trial exclusive 25 off so
check Aura out and let's get straight
back to the video so it's been about 12
hours that I implemented Brandon
sanderson's writing routine and I have
to say I really loved it I if I want to
give you one thing that you should take
from this video is definitely that
writing is a creative process and the
way it will look for you will be so
different than the way it will look for
me so the things that worked really well
for me is to focus on trying to write
500 Words an hour and try to push
through the initial barriers that you
may have and just start writing and also
the tip that he gave to write at the
same place at the same time every single
day really works for me but maybe you're
a little bit more a spontaneous writer
and you find these little hours in
between your routine that for you really
work and that for you you can really
focus on those moments I think for the
coming week as I'm working on my paper I
will definitely try to keep his tips in
mind and try to keep incorporating them
and hopefully it will improve my writing
a lot more because that's definitely
something that this year I want to work
on I also started this blog that you can
subscribe to if you're interested in
Neuroscience or notes on Neuroscience so
you can check that out and if you're
working on any kind of writing project
let me know what it is I am super
curious to hear and also if you have
some tips that make you a really good
writer or really fast writer also put it
down in the comments below such that we
can share it amongst the community and
thank you for watching this video and
see you next week bye